Speaker 1: We are now talking about Trump perjury.
Trump reportedly lying many times during a
completely unhinged deposition, which we have some
of the transcripts transcripts of. And the full
transcript is yet to be released, but apparently
will be. Newsweek reporting Donald Trump may
have severely damaged his case in the defamation
lawsuit brought against him by a woman who accused
him of rape by expressing, quote, repeated lies
during his deposition, according to an attorney.
Katie Phang, who's a legal analyst and MSNBC
host, was reacting to the unsealed transcripts
of testimony Trump gave. This is the Aegean Carol
lawsuit. Carol accused Trump of raping her in
the mid-nineties. Trump denies it. Carol is now
suing Trump for defaming her character, including
stating in a 2019 interview he wouldn't have
raped her because she is not his type. Which is.
An absolutely insane thing to say. Trump
later repeated the same remark on Troth
Central in October of 2020 to Troth Central
right before the deposition took place.
During his testimony, which was unsealed
Monday, Trump defended his not my type
remarks while calling the rape claim a hoax
and calling the accuser a whack job and a liar.
Fang said the legal significance is Trump steps
in it over and over again. And more importantly,
he basically denies flat out he's ever touched a
woman. And any part of her body specifically is
denying touching a woman on the breast or buttocks
or any other sexual part without her consent.
He said no under oath. The whole world knows
that. On an Access Hollywood tape, he boasted
about how he would grab them by the blank. And
you can do it when you're a star. He's caught in
repeated lies throughout the course of his sworn
videotaped deposition. There is now a bunch of
the transcript, and it is wacky. You can just
imagine Trump talking about this. He was asked,
you say she completely made up a story that
I met her at the doors of this crowded New
York City Department store and within minutes
swooned her. Do you see that? Trump says, Yeah.
What does swooned her mean? Trump. That would
be a word may be accurate or not having to do
with talking to her and talking to her to do an
act that she said happened, which didn't happen.
And it's a nicer word than the word that starts
with an F, And this would be a word that I used
because I thought it would be inappropriate
to use the other word and it didn't happen.
Anybody know what he's talking about? The question
that follows I was curious when I read this,
so I looked up the word swoon in the dictionary,
and under the dictionary it means to faint with
extreme emotion. That's not what you meant here.
Trump says, Well, sort of. That's what she said
I did to her. She fainted with great emotion.
She actually indicated that she loved okay.
She loved it until commercial break. In fact,
I think she said it was sexy, didn't she? She
said it was very sexy to be raped. Didn't she
say that? So, sir, I just want to confirm it's
your testimony that Jean Carroll said she loved
being sexually assaulted by you. Trump says, well,
based on her interview with Anderson Cooper,
I believe that's what took place. And we can
define that. You'll have to show that. I'm sure
you're going to show that. But she was interviewed
by Anderson Cooper, and I think she said rape was
sexy, which it's not, by the way, Trump clarifies
the. I hope we at some point get video of this
deposition because it is absolutely and completely
insane. But importantly, lying during a deposition
can have very serious legal consequences,
including perjury charges. Perjury is a criminal
offense. It can result in imprisonment. It can
result in fines. But, of course, remember, proving
perjury is very difficult. This is why I mean,
listen, you and I know people lie all the
time under oath in court. They say things
that aren't true. And many of them know that
the things they're saying are untrue. But why
don't you often see perjury charges? Because
in order to get a perjury charges stick,
you have to demonstrate that the person knew what
they were saying was untrue rather than it was the
result of a mistaken recollection or a lack of
recollection or whatever the case may be very,
very difficult. The other issue with lying during
a deposition is that you can be held in contempt.
This is all so unlikely to happen to Trump.
But it is again, more of Trump's dishonesty,
more of Trump's inability to just shut his
mouth and answer very directly only what is
being asked. And lawyers are now saying many,
many lies here, and it is perjury. What is
ultimately going to happen with the aging
Carol lawsuit? We don't know. Understand
that we now have the federal investigation into
Trump, the New York investigation into Trump,
the Georgia investigation into Trump, wherein a
grand jury recently finished its work. And we're
waiting. Could be any day we find out whether
Trump is going to be charged there. We have
this lawsuit. We have the cases against Trump's
organization. I'm sure I'm not even covering all
of it. And the next thing involves Rudy Giuliani,
including Rudy's claim that Trump told him, Hey,
Rudy, take some of these top secret files to
your house. Let's talk talk about that next.